7 febbraio 1992 a maastricht si radunano
gli esponenti dei principali paesi
europei per scrivere per siglare il
trattato di maastricht appunto una
pietra miliare nell'europa che loro
sognavano e nell'europa che oggi che
oggi noi conosciamo 7 febbraio 1992
io ricevo il mio primo personal computer
se avevo messo tanto a chiederlo io
allora avevo 12 anni e per me è stato un
passaggio fondamentale era mesi quasi
anni che cercavo di avere un pc anch'io
perché per me era un passaggio
importantissimo i miei amici i miei
coetanei già da anni avevano chi console
che il comodo chi l'ha mica insomma loro
potevano giocare col pc io no non sarei
mai riuscito a convincere i miei
genitori solamente con questa
motivazione e quindi gli raccontai e
loro fecero finta di crederci che mi
sarebbe servito per la mia carriera
scolastica e poi per la mia carriera
lavorativa
in realtà in parte era anche vero io
iniziai ad usarlo per rifarci a scrivere
le prime ricerche facevo la seconda
media e grazie all'utilizzo del computer
per esempio ne fai andare bene storia
dell'arte
io scrivevo malino disegnavo molto
peggio grazie all'uso del computer
inizia a fare ricerche molto più lunga e
molto più belle e molto più
particolareggiate e il professore smise
di dire ai miei genitori ma è quello
bravo che si impegna bene da allora è
cambiato tanto sono passati più di
vent'anni e oggi mi piacerebbe fare con
voi un racconto di condividere con voi
alcune delle esperienze che in questi
anni hanno portato al mondo del digitale
che tutti noi oggi conosciamo
sono certo che qualcuno starà pensando
sei un po troppo giovane per raccontarci
la storia dei computer è vero io non ho
visto la preistoria dei computer
io non sono cresciuto neanche
all'interno dei garage e di tutta una
serie di mindframe io non ricordo nulla
forse ho visto qualche video non vi
voglio raccontare la storia dei computer
non voglio avere questa presunzione ma
io da dieci anni lavoro nella fiancata
alle aziende per andare a progettare
esperienze utenti innovative per andare
a progettare servizi a misura dell'uomo
ecco su questo mi piacerebbe condividere
con voi un mini percorso ci sono tre
elementi in particolare che mi piace
mettere in evidenza oggi con voi per
raccontarvi un po come è cambiato il
mondo
il primo è l'approccio al manuale utente
negli anni ottanta negli anni 90 quando
prendevi un nuovo software quando
l'utilizzatore era costretto a
confrontarsi con un nuovo software si
trovava un importante manuale utente che
gli spiegava come quel software dovesse
funzionare il mio primo pc nel 92 aveva
come sistema operativo la ms dos
la ms dosso e veniva venduto in una
scatola con dei dischetti dentro e con
un bel manuale di fianco nel mio caso
era un 400 pagine e nessuno le leggeva
tutte ciascuno di noi chi più esperto
chi meno esperto si leggeva quel eventi
quelle 30 quelle 40 pagine che gli
servivano per fare le funzioni per le
operazioni per lui importanti e poi ci
si rivolgeva a un esperto di informatica
poco dopo nel 95 venne lanciato
microsoft windows 95
assolutamente non il primo probabilmente
neanche quello meglio fatto ma
sicuramente il più importante
nell'esperienza degli utenti normali
sistemi operativi e con le icone quindi
con un sistema che era alcun
un'interfaccia utente più umana beh
anche nel manuale si vide una certa
differenza io mi ricorda avevo un
manuale di 100 pagine introduzione a
microsoft windows era anche bello era
colorato c'erano le figure
insomma si entrava in un mondo che
sembrava più umano
oggi quanti di voi conoscono le
dimensioni anzi quanti di voi hanno mai
sfogliato il manuale di un sistema
operativo moderno di meco s di windows
10 piuttosto che di quello dell'iphone
del tablet
esistono sicuramente da qualche parte ci
saranno anche i manuali
la verità è che non sono più necessari
perché perché nel frattempo c'è stata
un'evoluzione importante allora non
c'era attenzione da chi sviluppava i
software a farli utilizzabili si dava
per scontato che poi l'utilizzatore
avrebbe imparato a usarli oggi invece si
è ribaltato il ragionamento si è
ribaltato il contesto oggi
l'applicazione deve essere usabile e
deve essere il più possibile vicina alle
conoscenze che già l'utente ha di fianco
ai manuali utenti che spariscono
ci sono delle linee guida di sviluppo
enormi per far sì che siano gli
sviluppatori dei software che devono
stare attenti a tutta una serie di
comportamenti per far sì che l'utente
non abbia bisogno di apprendere o che
deve apprendere il meno possibile
un altro evoluzione enorme è quella del
ciclo di vita dei software del ciclo di
vita dei prodotti negli anni ottanta
negli anni 90 il ciclo di vita del
software era per molti versi simile a
quello di un qualsiasi altro prodotto
meccanico per esempio c'era una fase
iniziale di progettazione
c'era una fase di costruzione di
produzione in questo caso quindi di
sviluppo del software e poi veniva messo
in una scatola nei suoi floppy disk e
distribuito non erano gli anni di
internet evidentemente quindi il ciclo
di vita era in tutto e per tutto un
ciclo di vita chiuso in cui poi le
evoluzioni successive del software che
veniva distribuito erano minime oggi non
è più così
oggi non è assolutamente così grazie
anche all'avvento di internet della
banda larga
i software sono connessi e
si stima che nei software di maggior
consumo che tutti noi utilizziamo penso
ai social network piuttosto che i
programmi di posta ma anche i programmi
ad uso industriale
ogni giorno subiscono 10 15
aggiornamenti si parla oggi di continuo
delivery che vuol dire evoluzione
continua del software
insomma c'è un team di sviluppo che
costantemente inserisce nuove migliorie
all'interno del software senza che
l'utente ne anche se ne accorga
proprio alla ricerca continua di un
miglioramento di un perfezionamento
nella direzione delle esigenze
dell'utilizzatore
il terzo passaggio è il terzo punto che
voglio mettere in evidenza e faccio un
po fatica anche a definire cosa sia
causa e cosa si effetto di questa
evoluzione è il concetto che la
tecnologia non è più lo special purpose
negli anni ottanta negli anni 90
all'inizio degli anni 2000 il computer
gli utilizzavamo li utilizzavano ma per
una singola esigenza negli uffici di
contabilità nelle amministrazioni c'era
il computer viene usato per le buste
paga nelle catene di produzione veniva
usato magari per i gestionali del
magazzino però il computer veniva usato
per quel specifico scopo come un
qualsiasi altro macchinario
oggi siamo totalmente immersi
all'interno di un contesto tecnologico e
il computer che poi è stato sostituito
oggi tutti noi abbiamo un tablet o di
tutti noi abbiamo uno smartphone con
dentro applicazioni digitali lo usiamo
costantemente senza ormai quasi
accorgersene dell'esigenza della
motivazione per cui lo usiamo oggi
quindi parliamo di human center design
la progettazione di servizi digitali
mettendo l'uomo a me piace parlare di
persona al centro
badate bene questo è un elemento molto
importante la differenza tra utente e
persona è una svolta epocale
l'utente è la persona come io me la
immagino nel mio contesto come io
sviluppatore come il produttore di
software me l'immagino nel mio contesto
io sono per esempio un'azienda che
produce un software per la gestione
delle buste paga per me l'utente non è
una persona per me l'utente è quello che
mi inserisce i dati cosa faccia nella
vita chi si sa quanti anni abbia non mi
interessava oggi parliamo di persona e
quando io sviluppo un software devo
tenere conto di tutte le esigenze
dell'ecosistema all'interno del quale
questa persona si muove se io il
progetto un software che deve essere
usato prevalentemente da ragazzini ne
devo tenere conto se io sviluppo un
software che viene usato prevalentemente
da persone di 55 anni con un livello
culturale non particolarmente avanzato
in ambito digitale ne devo tenere conto
io analizzo la persona la nuova
frontiera è quella della tecnologia
invisibile
la nuova frontiera è quella delle
interfacce di cui non me ne accorgo
l'interfaccia migliore è quella di cui
non mi accorgo e capite che qui c'è un
cambio importante del paradigma perché
pensa torniamo indietro torniamo agli
anni 90 agli anni 80 di cui vi parlavo
all'inizio io scrivevo da linea di
comando
cioè io la persona l'utilizzatore doveva
avere competenze tecnologiche e scrivere
dare input alla macchina nel suo
linguaggio
poi sono entrati strumenti che hanno
migliorato questa possibilità per
esempio il mouse che ci davano la
possibilità di lavorare una maniera
intuitiva che poi parliamo e chi mai ha
pensato in un qualsiasi altro contesto
di muovere con una mano un puntatore
quindi il fatto che fosse intuitivo è
tutto da dimostrare
oggi ci interfacciamo con la macchina
con tutta una serie di modalità che sono
effettivamente vicino all'uomo
parliamo di riconoscimento vocale parli
di linguaggio vocale naturale sono io
che parlo alla macchina col mio
linguaggio la macchina capisce che cosa
gli voglio dire questo è un cambio
epocale la macchina che decide che
capisce che cosa la persona gli ha
chiesto non è più la persona che deve
occuparsi di pensare con la testa della
macchina questo è il presente
questo è il futuro che tutti noi ci
attende
grazie
[Applauso]